[Musica]
io mi chiamo francesco virdis faccio il
chirurgo al lavoro nel settore pubblico
è nel settore umanitario motivo per cui
negli ultimi anni mi sono occupato dello
studio della politica di salute globale
presso la london school of hygiene
tropical medicine
oggi volevo introdurre il concetto di
bene pubblico globale con un particolare
focus nel mio ambito di competenza e
quindi sulla salute pubblica e di come
per la gestione della salute pubblica in
quanto bene pubblico globale sia
fondamentale la presenza di del diritto
internazionale di come le sue leggi
dovrebbero gestire la questo bene
globale in particolare situazioni di
emergenza come quelle per esempio che
stiamo vivendo nell'ultimo anno con il
covip quindi per introdurre il concetto
di bene pubblico globale
volevo giusto elencare due principali
caratteristiche di questo concetto il
bene pubblico globale è per definizione
un bene che è definito non escludente
il che vuol dire che chiunque può
accedere a questo bene è definito non
rivale cioè chiunque abbia accesso
questo bene sia esso un individuo una
comunità uno stato non preclude un altro
individuo comunità un altro stato dal
poterne usufruire
un esempio molto banale che mi viene in
mente potrebbe essere quello del del
faro per le navi la luce del faro delle
navi e accessibile a tutte le navi sia
essere s grandi piccole nelle di
commercio nave di trasporto di
passeggeri è il fatto che una nave abbia
accesso possa usufruire della luce del
faro non preclude le altre navi da
poterne usufruire ugualmente questo
porta anche a delle problematiche delle
problematiche di interesse
internazionale
una di queste la più comune forse il
fenomeno del free riding questo il
termine anglosassone che deriva dal
utilizzare i mezzi pubblici senza pagare
il biglietto che è in termini più
spiccioli possiamo tradurre come
scroccone un esempio è
quando uno stato per esempio decide di
mettere in atto delle politiche per
esempio per il cambiamento climatico per
ridurre quelli che sono i gas e quindi i
suoi effetti con riduzione dell'effetto
serra
e evidente come se uno stato menato
delle politiche a riguardo poi anche gli
altri stati che non hanno messo le
stesse politiche non hanno messo lo
stesso impegno nel ridurre i gas e
quindi l'effetto serra comunque
beneficeranno dell'effetto dovuto alle
politiche dell'altro stato e quindi è
chiaro come questo porti a livello
internazionale a degli squilibri tra gli
stati nella gestione di questo tipo di
bene pubblico
difatti il cambiamento climatico è un
altro esempio di bene pubblico globale
così come lo è la salute quindi per
quanto riguarda la salute pubblica
inteso come bene pubblico globale
diciamo che se vogliamo entrare nei
tecnicismi ci sono degli aspetti per cui
la salute pubblica
puoi anche essere definita un bene
rivale perché per esempio per far fronte
all'emergenza sanitaria che stiamo
vivendo adesso nelle malattie
trasmissibili l'accesso alle
vaccinazioni al sistema sanitari è
spesso un bene rivale perché non ci sono
vaccini disponibili per tutti
ma al di là dei tecnicismi è evidente
come la salute pubblica globale sia un
bene che interessa tutti gli stati e
quindi trascende quelli che sono i
confini degli stati sovrani e interessa
il mondo nella sua globalità e quindi
anche evidente come ci sia bisogno di un
organo che sia al di sopra di ciascun
stato sovrano che possa gestire
emergenze sanitarie come come questa
recente come quella che abbiamo vissuto
in passato e che possa dettare una delle
linee guida dei protocolli delle leggi
per risolvere queste problematiche in
maniera a 360 gradi in maniera
risolutiva
permanente oggi questo organo c'è si
chiama organizzazione mondiale della
sanità e ha il compito appunto di
gestire la salute pubblica a livello
globale ha il compito di creare delle
linee guida dei protocolli delle leggi
che possano far fronte alle emergenze
sanitarie
purtroppo però la sua autorità a livello
mondiale non è riconosciuta da tutti gli
stati o meglio è riconosciuta ma spesso
ci troviamo davanti agli stati sovrani
che decidono di non seguire in maniera
adeguata quelle che sono le indicazioni
che l'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità ha da per la gestione delle
problematiche di salute globale
brevemente l'organizzazione mondiale
della sanità è composta da tutti gli
stati appartenenti è che finanziano
l'organizzazione mondiale stessa quindi
i fondi che l'organizzazione mondiale
della sanità riceve vengono dai singoli
stati appartenenti nel 1982 fu congelato
quello che è il i fondi che ciascun
stato può dare alla organizzazione ma ci
sono dei dei fondi volontari che
ciascuno stato può dedicare
all'organizzazione e questo porta a uno
squilibrio tra quelli che sono stati più
ricchi ovviamente stati più poveri
oggigiorno gli stati uniti la cina il
giappone sono i maggiori finanziatori
delle l'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità questo crea anche un problema di
conflitto di interessi se vogliamo in
quanto spesso ci troviamo davanti a
situazioni in cui gli stati finanziano
determinati progetti e quindi a si
focalizzano più su progetti verticali
piuttosto che orizzontali creando delle
problematiche anche di tipo politico
oltretutto ci troviamo davanti a delle
situazioni in cui i singoli stati si
trovano al tempo stesso finanziatori e
clienti tra virgolette
dell'organizzazione e quindi gli stessi
finanziamenti possono essere ritirati
dagli stati a seconda dell'umore a
seconda degli interessi
16 economici in ballo l'organizzazione
modello della sanità come ho accennato
prima il compito di creare linee guida
protocolli leggi per proteggere la
salute pubblica intesa come bene globale
questo lo fa attraverso il diritto
internazionale diritto internazionale
prevede la formulazione di leggi che
sono definite leggi hard o leggi soft a
seconda che questi leghisti non
vincolanti o meno per gli stati membri
appartenenti all'organizzazione mondiale
della sanità
purtroppo oggi questo rimane più sulla
carta in quanto il termine vincolante
che in teoria dovrebbe far sì che tutti
gli stati rispettino le leggi
internazionali si traduce in realtà in
una sorta di anarchia anche qua tra
virgolette in quanto gli stati decidono
quando è se effettivamente rispettare
queste leggi e il problema in questa in
questa situazione è legato
fondamentalmente al fatto dell'assenza
di una autorità libero internazionale
che possa far rispettare le leggi e che
possa sanzionare i singoli stati
questo livello internazionale non c'è
manca a livello nazionale è evidente
come lo stato si fa autorità e si fa
carico di far rispettare le leggi ai
suoi cittadini tramite poi organi
giurisdizionali come la polizia
questo viene a mancare a livello
internazionale è tanto è vero che alcuni
giuristi non considero il diritto
internazionale come legge vera e propria
l'unico tipo di costo facciamo così che
i singoli stati hanno nel diritto
internazionale cosiddetto costo di
reputazione e cioè nel momento in cui
uno stato che inizialmente ha deciso di
abbracciare quel tipo di legge
internazionale poi si trova a non
rispettarlo
perde un po la faccia con tutti gli
altri stati membri
questo è definito costo di reputazione
ci sono stati che non hanno particolare
interesse in questo costo di reputazione
possiamo fare l'esempio degli stati
uniti
con l'amministrazione trump che ha
deciso di uscire per esempio degli
accordi climatici di parigi o quello la
decisione ancor più recente di stoppare
i finanziamenti all'organizzazione
modelli alla sanità allo stesso modo
possiamo citare l'esempio del governo
britannico con la pandemia del copit che
inizialmente decise di attuare delle
politiche completamente diverse da
quelle che erano state suggerite
l'organizzazione mondiale della sanità e
aveva deciso di attuare delle politiche
per una immunità di gregge senza
particolari misure restrittive per a un
certo punto premente intervenuto anche
quello che è il costo di reputazione il
governo ha cambiato un po la sua il suo
atteggiamento e ha deciso di rispettare
le indicazioni che l'organizzazione
mondiale della sanità aveva stabilito
l'importanza di rispettare quelle che
sono le indicazioni dell'organizzazione
mondiale della sanità è evidente anche
quando per esempio citiamo degli esempi
delle pandemie passate per esempio nel
2009 la cosiddetta suina o meglio la
h1n1
fu una pandemia in cui l'organizzazione
modelli della sanità decise di
intervenire in maniera un po insolita
decise di nominare appunto questa
pandemia con nome di suina perché aveva
visto che il virus era stato isolato sui
maiali pur specificando chiaramente che
non c'era nessun pericolo della
trasmissione del virus del maiale
all'uomo e che non c'era nessun motivo
di bloccare per esempio il commercio dei
suini non c'era nessun motivo di isolare
i maiali e così via quindi in questo
senso l'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità stava facendo il suo ruolo il suo
compito stava svolgendo il suo compito
di chiarire quali quali erano le
restrizioni al riguardo è di proteggere
quella che era anche un economia di cui
molti stati si fanno carico l'economia
che gira per esempio il torno al mercato
suino nonostante queste raccomandazioni
tantissimi stati
russia bahrein egitto decisero di
ignorare quelli che furono i consigli e
le indicazioni dell'organizzazione
mondiale della sanità uccisero centinaia
di migliaia di maiali bloccarono il
commercio del maiale creando delle
implicazioni ovviamente politiche
economiche molto importanti e questo
semplicemente per non aver seguito i
consigli delle organizzazione modelli
della sanità perché non avevano nessun
tipo di sanzione
in teoria avrebbero dovuto seguire
quelle che erano le indicazioni ma non
l'hanno fatto
facendo un po la figura anche un po
stupida se possiamo definire così perché
effettivamente si dimostrò ancora una
volta che non c'era nessun pericolo
nella trasmissione del virus da maiale a
uomo un'altra funzione importante
dell'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità è quella di dichiarare lo stato
di emergenza di carattere internazionale
abbiamo tutti visto cosa le conseguenze
di questo tipo di dichiarazioni nel
momento in cui in uno stato viene
dichiarata una pandemia i porti vengono
chiusi collegamenti vengono interrotti o
comunque ridotti quindi con delle
conseguenze politiche ed economiche
notevoli
ci sono degli stati che sono chiaramente
degli stati che sono più deboli e che
hanno risorse che non permettono
un'adeguata risposta sanitaria a
pandemie del genere
in questo senso l'organizzazione i
modelli della sanità un ruolo
fondamentale a questo livello
nella mia esperienza umanitarie ho
vissuto la seconda epidemia di ebola in
congo è ed era evidente come
l'intervento della ms e di tutte le
altre organizzazioni a livello del
livello
dello stato con volese siano state
fondamentali per risolvere l'epidemia di
ebola senza senza conseguenze diciamo
devastanti per il resto del mondo quindi
circoscrivendo poi l'epidemia quelli
stati e questo non sarebbe potuto
accadere senza appunto un coinvolgimento
internazionale senza degli aiuti
internazionali come quelli che ci sono
stati grazie all'attivazione dello stato
d'emergenza internazionale grazie a
tutte le misure linee guida e protocolli
che l'organizzazione modello della
sanità ha messo in atto un altro esempio
per far capire quanto beneficio si possa
attrarre nel seguire in maniera
appropriata in maniera rigorosa le
indicazioni dell'organo internazionale
dell'organizzazione ma della sanità è
per esempio la convenzione per il
riduzione del tabacco livello mondiale
se oggi non vediamo più pubblicità del
tabacco in televisione se oggi non
vediamo più fumare nei luoghi pubblici
se oggi abbiamo le immagini delle
patologie polmonari sui pacchetti di
sigarette emerito di politiche che dagli
anni 90 fino a oggi sono state messe in
atto dall organizzazione mondiale della
sanità e da tutti gli stati membri che
man mano nel corso degli anni hanno
deciso di abbracciare questo tipo di
politiche di rispettare queste leggi
internazionali
quindi è un classico esempio di come
seguire in maniera adeguata in maniera
rigorosa questo tipo di leggi
internazionali a un beneficio enorme per
quella che la salute pubblica globale
io mi avvio alla conclusione è spero di
essere riuscito a trasmettere il
concetto di come un organo
internazionale come l'organizzazione
mondiale della sanità attraverso il
diritto internazionale attraverso le sue
leggi hard e soft sia importante e
fondamentale nel gestire emergenze
sanitarie come quella che avevo vissuto
nell'ultimo anno e come sia importante
che i singoli stati membri agiscano
maniera non in maniera indipendente ma
in maniera coordinata nel rispetto di
queste leggi per assicurare una gestione
di questo tipo di emergenze a livello
globale in maniera efficace e risolutiva
[Musica]